okay so just so you know I am NOT a
hipster wearing one of those dumb shirts
this is actually a men black shirt so
you look there's the neuralyzer today's
the day and everything changes one way
or another
so men on alleged star Sam Wellington
Elizabeth Banks Edward Burns Edie Harris
Anthony Mackie Jamie Bel and Genesis
Rodriguez Sam Burlington was framed by
Edie Harris for stealing a diamond that
he did not steal
he got one day out of jail and he
managed to escape and now he is on a
Ledge trying to convince everyone around
him that he is innocent he's acting like
he's trying to commit suicide well
across the street there is the diamond
that he supposedly stole Jamie Bell
plays Sam Wellington's brother and he's
over there trying to break into that
place so he can find the diamond prove
that it is there that Sam Wellington
didn't actually steal it and thus
vindicate his brother and everyone goes
home happy
forty million dollar diamond going to
send me up the hook for this movie is
can we really feel riveted by the
situation a man on a Ledge for most of
the entire film how in the world are we
going to be you know into this is it
gonna be exciting it's gonna be boring
how is it and it's you know it's it's
all right this is actually one of the
better performance as I've seen from Sam
Burlington I really think that he was
good in this movie and that's something
that's really good about thrillers like
this I'm always for innocent men trying
to prove that they are innocent and not
guilty yet that always there's something
cool but that like the fugitive with
Harrison Ford is probably the best
example of that I can think how you see
me
it's your show bro let's make it rain
okay Joey you know what to do
everyone's looking at me anthony mackie
is good Elizabeth Banks is good even
Edward Burns was good I thought that
Jamie Bell in Genesys Rodriquez had a
lot of witty banter with each other that
I thought was entertaining and fun but
really the problem with this movie lies
with the writing it's just so convoluted
towards the last half it really just
gets to the poem you're like really
really oh really come on I mean almost
every movie requires a sense of
disbelief and man on the ledge requires
a lot of it and it gets to the point
where it becomes a little bit tedious
and you're and you just don't really buy
it anymore
yeah but you go to take down a man it's
stole everything from me however the
movie has good things about it the
acting is good the direction is OK
there's nothing wrong with it but I
really felt like he didn't utilize the
suspense of the situation that much
there's really only a couple shots where
I got the the wiggly wobbly 's whatever
I bought that he was actually on the
ledge of a building but I just didn't
really feel that suspense by the
situation and I feel like that could
have been handled a lot better the plan
is to prove that I'm innocent the
monarch diamond never lifts his hands
pick up we got a problem here
finally all in all it's an okay movie
there's nothing special about it it's
it's it's a passable time it's perfect
for like a rental if it's raining
outside and you got nothing to do
maybe rant man on a ledge not necessary
to see it in theaters b-minus
what's your favorite innocent man on the
run thriller mine is the fugitive I love
the fugitive it wasn't me it was the
one-armed man if you liked this review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck me now